today we are going to have a look at the
prepper lifestyle we're gonna head to
Central Texas where a good friend of
mine John Stokes a former technology
writer lives he started a tech website
called ARS technica he now helps run a
website called the prepared comm
obviously this this virus has kind of
turned all of us into Preppers hoarding
our food and toilet paper and everything
else and so we're gonna get some tips
from a pro on how to live like a prepper
and how to deal with this virus head-on
so off we go to see John Stokes hello
hello can you guys hear me yeah man
I can hear you but I can't see your
beautiful face yeah started the video
thank you some Texas on the wall back
coming in hot man coming in strong I
like it this wall which has like axes
and other tools on it
you guys gonna be doing like video
tutorials and stuff right and until you
garan up some of that that's the plan
yeah we're gonna do some some lessons
that is quality so yeah I'm John Stokes
I'm deputy editor at the prepared comm
and I was originally more of like a
classic Boy Scout I was a life scalp I
grew up in hurricane country Gulf Coast
Louisiana I knew what it was to bug out
for hurricane you know evacuate that
kind of stuff so I was more along that
vein we sold Ars Technica in 2008 and
May of 2008 and then so I was kind of a
newly minted investor in a member of the
investing class and then boom Lehman
happens in September the kind of one-two
punch of the financial crisis and
becoming a father those both tipped me
over into into serious preparatory and
we see that a lot at the prepared the
first kid is
period when a lot of parents get into
this I kind of became aware that you
know hey mad the world sort of runs on
short-term credit and this is a weird
vulnerability that I didn't know existed
I didn't know that if you couldn't get
short-term credit then there may not be
groceries there may not be clean
municipal water stuff like this and so
then you start thinking what are the
other vulnerabilities just like with the
Great Depression there was a generation
there had hoarded things and that was
you know was thrifty it's gonna leave
its mark yeah how did you approach
getting into this whole world you know I
had started a outdoor website called all
outdoor comm for a friend of mine who
have a company and an ad network and
they're like we want to make our own
content sites so I started this site for
them mostly it was outdoor gear hunting
shooting fishing that kind of stuff and
so I started rolling in the preparedness
stuff and the audience liked it and I
just started writing about it and and
research and as I wrote about it I was
fortunate in that the same people that
owned that site also own survival
survivalist boards comm and so I had a
connection to the more traditional side
of the survival community there's a
little difference between survivalists
and Preppers so I was a little more
plugged into the survivalist side but
also some of the prepping stuff as it
started to it have you seen a ton of
people a lot more new people coming to
the site yeah there's been a lot of
interest we've had a lot of new people
sign up and join and there's still maybe
some residual stigma around the word
prepper but in terms of the number of
people that are engaging and what we
would recognize this now as prepper
activities that's gonna go through the
roof and it's gonna stay elevated this
is the kind of medium term food supply
there's some short term stuff that's
that's in the refrigerators downstairs
we bought an extra fridge we've got a
lot of canned food that's a barrel Bryce
I got a cheese wheel I actually got to
cheese wheels and what what kind you get
Dutch Gouda cheese wheel like a 20 pound
wheel and then I got like a sheep's milk
/ goat's milk blend cheese wheel it's
protein and fat in there and it keeps
for like 25-30 years we've got batteries
and a charging station so I do a lot of
rechargeable batteries here that's a
kind of a little mini attic storage
air conditioned so that's where there's
a lot of long-term food and so this was
a playroom that we turned into like a
little mini classrooms for the kids
because now they have to go from home
bunch of games behind me I've gotten
into board games for those you know can
you prepare for a virus the same way as
like a natural disaster or something
like that we try to start with a
baseline of you you don't make any
assumptions so when we look at the bug
out bag there'll be a lot of stuff in
there that's of the nature of okay I'm
stuck out and there's no services I've
got a clean canteen here this is a
single walled Klean Kanteen it's not the
double wall because you can pull out
water in it a tarp toilet paper headlamp
sleeping pad day trek trash and block
this is a titanium pot there's a tender
stranded here so you can light a fire
with the straw contractor bags Ranger
bans and fasteners holding saw you want
to start with a baseline of super core
stuff having some lighting have an
ability to make a fire or have a water
have it some food and then you tweak up
from there and and prepare for certain
certain other kinds of emergencies I I
think the thing to do is is to not get
complacent and to be ready to take the
next step
I really have actually spent a lot of
time the past two weeks repack and these
bags and making sure that we're actually
ready to go I'm looking into our home
insurance or we insured up have to leave
this property and I come back and it's
trash do have everything documented what
what about documents and I'm getting
those together a will so I am hoping for
things to get better in the spring I'm
hoping for us to turn the corner and for
us to go back to to reopen society but I
don't know what's next and so I'm I'm
spinning my time as best I can
preparing for an even worse case
scenario and that'd be my general
recommendation is you've got time
whatever you can do you don't have to do
all the things maybe you're just
exercising maybe you're going around
your apartment your house and you're
looking for okay if I got off in the
middle then
I had to leave because it was unsafe or
for whatever reason what am I gonna take
put that stuff together do it now you
got a minute you can do it now the
important thing is not to get too
attached to any one thing not to get too
attached to a piece of property to a
piece of stuff you don't want to have
that cloud your judgement about what's
the safest for you
hope for the best keep preparing for the
worst well man I appreciate you spending
the time and giving us this advice I'm
sorry it sort of took this thing for us
to like see each other face to face
again is we got to do this under happier
circumstances
but yeah thank you so much all right
thank you guys
you